okay call this one GDP served Italian
style Italy is changing how it
calculates its gross domestic product a
measurement of the overall economy to
include the black market everything from
prostitution to arms trafficking to
illegal drug sales economists predict
the illegal sales will add one point
three percent to GDP this year hey it's
one way to boost your growth right but
it could also backfire and after all the
criticism Italy received for former
prime minister silvio berlusconi's
indiscretions and fraud conviction this
won't help the country's image by
including the black market for which
there are no concrete ways to measure
and accurately determine value the
Italian government is going to be able
to calculate its GDP numbers in a way
that is bound to open it to criticism
and at least annoy its northern
neighbors simultaneously investors will
learn to dismiss or to discount at the
very least Italy's statistics since they
won't be regarded as real now the reason
Italy is becoming creative with its
accounting is because it wants to and
the European Union needs it to look
better on paper after all a larger
overall economy will enable Italy to
lower its debt to GDP ratio which is of
course an essential part of meeting the
e use financial standards so
theoretically this should enable Italy
to borrow more money you can think of it
like this if a family's annual income
goes up it would qualify for a bigger
mortgage though if income went up
because the family robbed a bank the
family's creditworthiness wouldn't
exactly be enhanced now while Italy's
move may be considered on Orthodox even
shady it's definitely not illegal in
fact the EU encourages this creative
accounting in order to give countries
like Italy a lifeline new EU rules
require member states to include the
value of all income producing activity
in GDP calculations and illegal activity
is often an income-producing activity
Italy is the first and only country
though to take advantage of this so far
but others like Spain for which twenty
percent of the overall economy is
believed to be black market and Greece
may soon follow the beauty of the black
market at least if you're the borrower
is that its value can be interpreted
however you want so in the US for
example the illegal marijuana business
estimated to be worth between 10 billion
and a hundred billion dollars that is a
pretty big spread and it all has to do
with how an economist actually measures
those numbers so if you're an economist
in Italy who needs to make your economy
look better you'll want to go with those
liberal calculations but the truth is no
one really knows bottom line here the
real danger in padding GDP with black
market activity is that it will cement
the distinction between the more austere
outlook of Northern Europe with the
so-called la dolce vita lifestyle of the
southern neighbors you can read more in
my USA Today op-ed column out today